[Applause]
[Music]
so thank you this year's laureate Jim
Allison was born in the small South
Texas town of Alice in 1948 from an
early age he was drawn to science he
played with his chemistry Sept and was
fascinated by dissecting frogs his
father was a doctor in the town Jim
Allison sometimes accompanied him on
house calls but when doing that he
realized that following in his father's
footsteps wasn't exactly what he wanted
during high school he ran into teacher
would not teach evolution Allison took
this very very seriously to him biology
without Darwin was like physics without
Newton he therefore refused to take the
class and this put him in danger of
actually failing high school fortunately
a compromise was reached he fulfilled
the requirements by taking college
biology by correspondence with
University of Texas where later also
received bachelor's and PhD in
biochemistry as an immunologist dr.
James Allison's fundamental discoveries
in parallel with others include defining
the structure of the t-cell antigen
receptor demonstrating that cd28
provides co-stimulatory signals
necessary for full t cell activation and
showing that ctla4 is an inhibitory
checkpoint which impedes activation of
t-cells all of this was basic research
and based on his basic research Allison
was the first to propose and demonstrate
that immune checkpoint blockade might be
a powerful strategy to treat tumors as
we will hear more about he was also
involved in the development of he
believed him up a monoclonal antibody
which was approved by FDA
for treatment of metastatic melanoma
seven years ago dr. Allison is a member
of the National Academy of Sciences and
the National Academy of Medicine he has
received numerous awards including the
Lifetime Achievement Award from the
American Association of immunologists
the law jay old award the Novartis award
in clinical immunology the Medal of
Honor in basic research from the
American Cancer Society the Harvey prize
in human health the breakthrough prize
in Biosciences The Wolf Prize and in
2015 the Lasky DeBakey clinical medical
research award now if he hadn't been and
become a scientist Jim Allison may well
have become a musician he has played the
harmonica at least casually since his
youth he told me that he became more
serious in playing the harmonica during
his postdoctoral years in California and
this culminated with playing on stage
with Willie Nelson at the Stingaree bar
by the sea
in downtown San Diego now that wouldn't
be Allison's
last run-in with Willie Nelson and his
band it so happened that Nelson's
longtime harmonica player Mickey
Raphael read about Allison's research in
the newspaper and he then invited him to
come and play with the band so in 2016
in what he calls one of the five best
moments in his life
Allison and Raphael traded harmonica
solos on stage with Willie Nelson and
they remained friends to this day
please welcome this year's laureate
Jim Allison
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You dr. Smith and mr. president
and members of the selection committee
and members of the Nobel assembly I'm
really honored to have the opportunity
to speak to you all noted guests here
and give you some insights into what
we've been doing and why I've been doing
it for the last several years I'd like
to dedicate this this talk to the many
students and fellows that have trained
with me and really done the work that
I'm going to be talking about over the
years and also to the doctors and the
patients that were involved it had no
small risk to themselves in the early
clinical trials and finally to my
partner in life in science dr. Pat
Manish Sharma with whom much of the work
I was doing to show you is done in
collaboration no where's the and so the
people tried to list some of these
people of course they aren't all up
there but the people whose names are in
red or people who contributed
specifically to the new work I'm going
to show you later today and what I want
to try to do is show you the early stuff
that we did leading up to the idea of
checkpoint blockade show you where
that's at and then finished with some
mechanistic studies that have provided
some surprising new insights and how
this actually occurs so why would you
want to use immunotherapy to treat
cancer well I think we all know now that
the cancers of disease of many diverse
gene mutations ultimately the teeth the
tumor cells become highly and unstable
with respective genomic integrity and so
it really can be viewed as many
different cancers each independent of
histah type each which are caused by
distinct genetic mechanisms but one of
the things we've learned since the war
on cancer started is that trying to
target these single causative mutations
with targeted small molecules always
essentially leads to relapse after
response and that's because there's so
many mutations by the time you target
one there's already a resistant
mechanism which the tumor can use to
after selection to bypass it
but t-cells which has been my love ever
since I heard about them in graduate
school offer three things that really
other kinds of cancer treatment do not
and the first one is specificity I think
that everybody knows that t-cell
recognized peptides on the surface of
the cells presented by MHC molecules
that tell the immune system what's going
on in them and we know now from worker
Bob Schreiber and many others that in
the case of t-cells they're focused on
the mutations products of the mutations
that occur in the tumor cell not just
the ones that cause it
which is what targeted therapies do but
pretty much any of them so you can get
polyvalence see about targeting these
because the immune system doesn't know
what the mutations are doesn't know
whether they're cause they were not and
doesn't matter they just tell them you
system something's different the second
thing is what you've got t-cells a
number of them become four slowly
renewing memory cells and so they're
there for the rest of your life
basically and can be reawakened if
necessary to come after the tumor again
and finally the immune system is very
adaptable
you've probably got 50 to 70 million
different T cells circulating around
which in that cost that can change with
time since the immune system is
generating new and still immune system
can adapt spontaneously the changes in
the tumor and so it's easily a match to
cancer which is the whole theme of this
talk so I'm just going to condense a lot
of work here to get about it on the same
page and in 1982 we worked out the
structure of the antigen receptor
heterodimer but with antibodies a number
of labs showed after that that soon
after that that signaling through the
t-cell receptor by itself is not
sufficient to activate t-cells you need
an additional co stimulatory signals
were provided only by very specialized
cells such as dendritic cells in 1988 we
showed that that receptor for those
signals was a molecule called cd28
and others show that there were ligands
farter b7 but we there was an awesome
also a molecule called ctla-4 which had
an unknown function it was only known
that it did not was not expressed until
after T cell activation
so current view is when the t-cell gets
a t-cell receptor signal and a cd28 co
stimulatory signal you turn on two
pathways to two programs shown in green
there are a lot of genes that associated
whose products were associated with cell
proliferation because we have to expand
a few dozen cells of any particular type
to hundreds of thousands of cells very
quickly to get the soldiers in the field
to attack the cancer but you also
started this wasn't really realized
until about 1994 you also start an off
program by induction of the program
induced by seek like for expression
which eventually accumulates in a cell
and can turn t-cells off so without
going through all the work one of the
things that we had shown in the meantime
is that tumor cells lining Mouse tumor
cells have plenty of antigens and we
showed that because we put b7 molecules
into them so that they can provide
co-stimulation they'll immediately get
rejected but normally they're not
rejected because they're invisible to
the immune system not because they lack
antigens because they can't give the
second signal and so I reasoned at the
time that and you can't start it on your
response until tumor cells die and they
specialized to dendritic cells come in
pick up the bits of dying tumors
redisplay the antigens on their surface
in the context of b7 so this cross
priming then initiates an immune
response against ISA against tumor cells
and but then see today for of course is
the normal process is induced and so
it's a kind of race you know the tumors
had a head start and if the tumor gets
to such a mass as the T cells can't
generate enough to take care of it we
thought then the tumor wins because they
would be turned off I seeked like 4 so
we had the idea of just disabling the
brakes by putting in an antibody to see
to look for a very simple process and
just keeping the brakes on living the T
cells keep running well we did this well
anyway what that's shown on this cartoon
in the right and there's there's a
couple of features there that are that
are very interesting when I first
thought of this one is that we're not
we're targeting the immune system not
the tumor cells so the kind of cancer
doesn't make any difference it's
make any difference because you know all
tumors have neo antigens and that really
doesn't matter what kind of cancer say
we don't have to make a new drug for
every cancer cell it's a universal
therapy that can be potentially used for
any kind of cancer and the second one is
since it started by cross priming you
can take advantage of that priming by
death to use in combination with
chemotherapy radiation hormone therapy
whatever kills some tumor cells and give
agents that do those things properties
of the immune therapy as well and so
there we go sorry and so the idea of
course is wonderful idea but does it
work and so this just shows one of the
first experiments we did we've got you
know transplantable tumors growing in
the backs of mice
you see untreated they grow we have to
euthanize the mice block cd28 there go
faster but if we inject antibiotics to
seek life for the tumor grows for a
while then gets rejected and so when I
got this result I was I was amazed not
expected to slow the tumor but it just
completely eliminated I'm covering up
this one molecule out of everything
that's going on was sufficient to give
tumor rejection so just to make a long
story very short after two years delay
because people in part couldn't
understand how you could treat cancer by
ignoring the cancer cell and treating
the immune system we worked with the
company called meta axon later he had a
human seats left for antibody called epi
luma map and this is a patient in a
phase one trial started about 2000 this
is May 2001 actually what she started
you can see these big tumors in her long
she had metastatic melanoma that had
failed every therapy including high-dose
I'll too and a dendritic cell vaccine
she got one injection of three MiG's per
kig of CT for and I happened to visit
Toni Remus her doctor in 2011 10 years
after she'd gotten an injection
the cat scan on the right is from her
10th year checkup after
in a single injection and she's actually
still doing fine she's almost nineteen
years out now from metastatic melanoma
and I should point out that when we
started this work the median life
expectancy after diagnosis with with
metastatic melanoma was 11 months so it
was essentially a death sentence and
there was no drug that had ever
prolonged life at any level whatsoever
so there are a lot of trials done
resulting in a phase 3 registration
trial with overall survival is the
endpoint which took almost four and a
half years to complete and what you can
see here is this is the if you liver may
have line this one this is the placebo
control here and what you can see is
removed the survival over about four
months which would have been sufficient
for FDA approval because no drug had
ever done that before but as you can see
here very interesting thing happens
between two and three years it's a
survival curve flattens out and stayed
that way for the duration of the trial
which means basically nobody is dying of
the disease after about three years and
so at by 2015 there was follow-up data
of several thousand patients what you
can see here is it's the same at three
years and kind of flattens out stays
that way for ten years and about twenty
a little over twenty percent of the
patients so I think for all intents and
purposes for this disease people that
make it past four years I really think
you can consider them to be cured and
they don't have to worry about you know
what's going to go on I wouldn't say
that lightly
it's based again on several thousand
patients so with this disk file up
therapy but the question is why isn't it
a hundred percent you know why isn't
just a fraction there's a number of
mechanistic reasons why that might be
true but of course there's another
possibility that there were other
checkpoints and and dr. hangzhou had
discovered a molecule called pd one and
by about 2001 it was shell there was
another checkpoint actually and it
differs in a couple of important ways
one of them is that one of its ligands
could actually be expressed on the
surface of tumor cells an induced by
gamma interferon made by the cd8 cell
what that means is they
that rather than working at priming like
ctla4 it's working on fully
differentiated cells at the end of their
development and turning off the
functional cells by interaction PD Awad
on the tumor cell with PD one on the T
cell and I'll come back to that in
detail in a while anyway there is very
quickly this way into clinical trials
this is a summary of a phase one trial
done by Santa Paula and very good
results in melanoma non-small cell lung
cancer renal cancer no responses and
colorectal cancer although later on Bert
vogelstein shows there's a subset that
as genomic instability that has
microsatellite instability defects and
DNA damage repair this subset has a
large number of mutations and patients
with that defect do respond and then
there's also no responses to castrate
resistant prostate cancer and I'll show
you later that we think figured out why
that is and you know way around it so
where do we go well obviously
combinations you've got two different
drugs that work at different stages of
t-cell development and so put them
together so this is a trial when if
several really put together by Jed
wallchuck and others this is the IPPY
lua mab only arm and you can see here
the ANA and our PD well then they will
vote you're mad about it here plus and I
see two like four there's a 60% response
right now when you combine those two
functionally different checkpoints and
the last time I checked the survival is
out to about four years on these
patients so we're getting close to the
point of knowing whether this is going
to be as durable as if you do them
abalone and there's no reason to think
that it won't be and so I think we've
gone hears of this remarkably from a
almost uniformly fatal disease to being
able to get meaningful responses the
last perhaps for decades as well with
this combination in 60% of melanomas and
so that's the best response thing and a
lot of people say well this is just a
melanoma drug that's not really true
there various trials have been done the
FDA's approved these these edges for
non-small-cell lung cancer
for renal cell cancer Hodgkin's lymphoma
bladder cancer head and neck Merkel cell
which is a very even more lethal form of
skin cancer also gastric cancer in a
pallet cellular carcinoma and I'll come
back to this this is really a remarkable
approval so any tumor of any histo type
that has defects in DNA damage repair
and consequently has high low levels of
neo antigens can be treated regardless
of what kind of cancer they are for the
first time it's ever been approval for a
particular genetic defect and in a class
of tumors and so we're in a pretty good
setting we know a lot of tumors respond
not all and not all of them is high a
fraction as we would like so to go
forward really in a rational way we need
to know the cellular mechanism alekhya
your mechanisms of the effects so that
we can you know design the best way to
combine things and develop strategies
for identifying patients who are going
to respond and so at MD Anderson dr.
Sharma and I built on some work that
she'd been for some time and in genital
urinary cancers to develop what we call
the the immunotherapy platform and the
goal of this is to do mechanistic
studies on any patient with any kind of
cancer that's being treated with any
drug that would have impacted immune
system of course we defined that as
anything basically and the idea is to
get tissue and blood from them and
analyze it by all the techniques that we
can to get some insight into what's
going on and I'm going to go through the
details but so far we've got enrolled
over 3,000 patients have gotten matched
samples of tissue and blood from those
patients and so I'll just show you one
brief thing about what how we've used
this to study what's going on in
prostate cancer so as I told you there
were no responses in a phase one with
with PD one with with early child so VIP
ulama map there were respond there's a
small number but remarkable responses
of men whose PSA was undetectable and
had metastasis disappear and and
symptomatic relief no thanks so this
went to a phase three trial
shown here which and fortunately failed
there was no real significant difference
between the if people ooh may have only
you know treatment and the placebo
control and so we wanted to find out
what that was so using dr. Sharma's
approach this which is to do with
localized as treatment with localized
cancers what's called a pre surgical
trial where the patients are given a
couple of doses of this case if you live
in lab before they go to surgery and so
these were guys that were given two
doses before they would prostatectomy
and so at the time of surgery we get the
whole organ you know - what the
pathologist needs for diagnosis we get
the whole organ and for studies and we
can pretty much do anything we want from
flow cytometry to multiplex tissue
sections RNA expression genomic sequence
is such a really powerful technique to
get data and so this is what we found on
the left column here these are mr.
chemicals I mean it has to chemical
slides what you can see here is before
treatment no cd4 is virtually no CDH
very few regulatory t-cells for a few
memory cells etc but after two doses of
Appeal umem AB it goes from I'm not sure
the comparative size but this looks a
lot like pancreatic cancer at baseline
where after treatment you could see
robust infiltration with cd4 cd8 Fox b3
t reg cells these cells just get this
activated killer cells here and
macrophages so this now becomes to look
like melanoma and so just to show you
what happens though so CT four drives
the t-cells into a coal tumor but it
also induces all these inhibitory
markers as you can see here with PTO
PTL one Vista PD one and lagg-3 so all
of those are inhibitory molecules that
were induced by if you live in lab
treatment so you can see the numbers of
cells where you see the cells here with
PD one PDL one and vista so these are
two very different inhibitory molecules
when you look at the numbers you can see
the PDL one is induced on the cd8
t-cells themselves as well as on
macrophages and the tumor cells whereas
Vista is induced to a little bit on cd8
cells but mostly on macrophages in other
studies that I won't show you we know
that PDL one and Vista are always
expressed by different subsets of
macrophages they aren't ever found on
the on the same cell and so this then
led to propose something obvious about
the at this time back mr. Barr squibbitt
shut down their entire prostate program
because you know PD one didn't do
anything and then acetyl f4 did it
occasionally but not enough to be
considered significant so we went to
lemon showed showed him those data said
we need to give it VP to drive the
t-cells in and then in a PD one or PD
one logon to cover up those that
inhibitory pathway that was induced by
ap liver may have and so what you can
see here is one of the patients these
are PSA levels his PSA levels have been
rising for some time hitting almost 500
when he got the first dose of anesthesia
for a month later the second dose a
month later the third dose by then it
was essentially at baseline and a fourth
doors here anyway the patient's
metastases completely disappeared and it
was a complete responder symptomatic
relief and everything so there were a
few of these in the trial so with some
fiddling with the dose it was a little
bit toxic in the way that was done it's
being reopened with a few hundred
patients and hoping will lead to
registration for the treatment
of castrate-resistant prostate cancer
and so for the rest of the talk I want
to really talk about the differences
between these two there's a tendency to
say you know we've got two checkpoints
and one of the things that people
figured out right away is that is that
PT 1 has fewer adverse events then and
seek late for blockade and so let's just
use PT 1 but point I want to make here
is that these are very different drugs
it's not just that they're but
checkpoints and you don't have to think
about as I told you see July 4 is
hardwired it's part of every immune
response that your body makes whereas PD
one is induced resistance like yeah I'm
at a fair on most of time inducing PDL 1
it's also been shown to play a role in
other settings and the protection of the
developing embryo from maternal attack
on fetal antigen so we think that this
is a protective mechanism it's just
co-opted by cancer cells to protect them
from the same mechanism as I showed you
or the cartoon shows the CTA for works
mainly during priming pd-1 on exhausted
cells
ctla4 I'm not going to show you a data
but it's been shown in several settings
to refute new t-cells and expand clonal
diversity
whereas pd-1 doesn't seem to do that it
could expand the clones that are already
there and number but doesn't allow
recruitment of new clones so I'll show
you see to look for primarily affects
cd4 cells whereas PD one only he
actually only affects cd8 cells as I
showed you toast if you little map seats
like forked drive T cells into Cole
tumors PD one doesn't the responses
again because it works it's priming to
an acetyl i-4 offered very slow where
there's rapid too
pd-1 which you might expect since that's
just your reactivating already
differentiated cells and I mentioned the
adverse events and one of the things of
becoming a parent the disease recurrence
after response with seek life for a very
rare in melanoma at least they'll
usually focal and then she could be
dealt with my surgery you know whereas
disease recurrence after responses with
pd-1 are pretty significant is about
fifteen percent or so in melanoma and
twenty five percent in and lung cancer
resistance mechanism to include loss of
gamma interferon sensitivity and other
things so in order to just sort of get a
really unbiased way and although it's
biased that were just looking at t-cells
here and what plays a role in the
response we use site off time of flight
cytometry where I'm not gonna go through
I'm sure everybody's heard about it but
he uses antibodies coupled to heavy
metal ions that can be distinguished
very sharply you know mass spec and so
you can do up to forty three parameters
and so what we did was to use one for
live dead a few for looking at dividing
cells and then a few for bar coding
because we mix everything and analyze it
together and then D convoluted but many
group things by a tizzy plot called by
just putting things which look more like
the cells in the grouping here and then
we can identify what those are by
different markers and then we measure
different clusters of the frequency of
the cells in different clusters and then
we keep track for every mouse that we
look at we keep track of the size of the
tumor when it was harvested and then we
can relate any particular changes that
we see with the ones that the changes
that are important to the size of the
tumor and so the way that experiments
done is that we give mice to MERS give
AM antibody different intervals and then
they thirteen in the case of MC
we harvested look at the tissues now I'm
going to show you just data on MC 38
which is a fairly high mutation load
immuno genic tumour the response to both
these agents by themselves and but we
also got the same results usually it's
Gila called B 16 B l6 which is very low
in mutational load it's not affected by
mono therapies with these antibodies so
we have to use a vaccine with it but the
results were the same
with both of them so this is what the
the MC 38 tumor looks like when you gate
on lymphocytes and then our bone marrow
drive cells and then t-cells
our cells Express CD 3 epsilon and so
here the it's just dot plots basically
representing you know each dot
representing a cell
Blue is mice that got control antibodies
red is nice to God and I see too late
for a green is - they got PD 1 and so
what you can see here is that is that
there's a real positive of well actually
let me start down here you look here
with NKT cells in Gamma Delta cells is
essentially random there's nothing going
on they're just equally mixed but what
you can see here is there's a real pal
city of red dots compared to blue or
green and amongst the T rags so this is
something that actually was first
noticed by surgical Allah and Tyler
Simpson in my lab I suppose by Allen
Corman slab several years ago and that
in the mouse the an acetal 8:4 antibody
can deplete regulatory C cells T cells
because they expressed so much seats
like for mechanism involving macrophages
mediating antibody dependent
cytotoxicity so that's that and there's
controversy as to whether this happens
and humans are not we don't think it is
and I'll show you some data you know a
little while but then here are the cd4
effector cells this is all T c4 cells
except the ones that have
Fox p3
and you can see here there's an
over-representation of red dots so these
cells are being expanded by seats like
for when you get to the cd8 area here
you can see that overall there seems to
be a big increase with pd-1 but there
are patches where secretly four is
expanding cells and so this is overall
what's going on but what you can do of
course is do a FINA graph where you line
up each cluster with all the marker
genes that they expressed so we had all
the marker genes from the major cell
surface at incidence and differentiation
transcription factors in this panel and
so just to make this approachable more
visible and here we divide them by cell
type again no difference of the NKT
cells T regs there's two kinds there's
one kind that they all have Fox p3 one
has a maturation engine called KLR g1
those cells and the smaller population
that archaeology was negative you see
here look like they're depleted by C too
late for treatment if you look at the
cd4 effector cells there's there's
really two major populations there's
these cells that I'm going to talk a lot
about these cells for the rest of the
lecture
these cells are th one like would call
them teach one like because they have T
bet and so they make a lot of get'em
interferon and TNF alpha but they also
have AI costs which is makes them a
little bit strange and I'll come back to
what this is a little bit later but
those cells are very strongly associated
with decrease in tumor size whereas this
other population which do it just looks
like an uninvited T so don't really do
anything
and then I activate a cd4 they don't
really do anything with PT one what you
see is a preference for preferential
increase in a subset of cd8 cells that
have high PD one hi Tim three you're
also high lag three
so these are what we call exhausted
they're terminally differentiated but
they're also functionally exhausted they
do not divide left themselves but
they're dividing here when you give a
tacitly and a PD one they start dividing
and these are also very strongly
associated with smaller tumor size but
what is obvious from from these data is
that despite the fact that they've been
treated with data PD one antibody
they're still expressing PD one so if
the antibody goes away these cells are
going to stop dividing again we haven't
changed the phenotype at all and this is
also supported by some work from John
weary who's shown there's epigenetic
changes in the PD one gene that lock it
on in these cells you can't do anything
about that and those are not increased
significantly by ctla-4 treatment then
there are cells here that are pd-1
intermediate they also are terminally
differentiated and that they express the
openings at civil other markers but
they're they're not exhausted and you
can see these are expanded by both seats
like four and pd1 those also are
strongly associated with decrease in
tumor size and then there's these cells
which look like naive t-cells again and
these cells which are they're expanded
by seats like four as well then these
cells which look like recently activated
t-cells and and they're actually
associated with bigger tumor size so
these are getting in the way of the
responses so we've really got three
populations one cd4 which expanded just
by seats left for one cd8 which is
expanded just by PD one and then this
group which expanded by both that
associated that if those are the cells
that are playing the main role in
shrinkage of tumor cells and so this
just sort of summarizes that the
mechanist is very you know are different
and that may be why when you put these
two things together
everything works it works much better
we're working on that now and have some
data in review but measuring these
subtypes is a lot more informative than
just measuring total cd4 and cd8 it's a
telling who's going to respond and the
other thing is that the therapeutic
details didn't really matter in this
experiment and so does this happen in
humans well this is not obviously as
easy to do as it is it - we could only
find because the standard of care now is
both antibodies we can only find one
patient that was treated with just at a
PD Watt and a few that were treated just
with and a fantasy too late for and only
a small group that were been treated
with and a PD wand and so this just
shows the same roof and the point is
that essentially the same is the group
is expanded largely about PD one and
these are these exhausted CD aids and
then the cd4 the high cost positive side
gets expanded again by seats life or we
can see here mono therapy and then also
by combination therapy you can see here
t rags are not depleted by that I notice
each leg for the other thing I want to
point out is that the only control that
we had here with normal donor PBMC and I
just want to point out that there are
none of these cells the ones that are
effective with with c24 we can't find
those using this panel of antibodies we
cannot find them in the normal blood and
so I come back to that a little while I
think that's that's very significant
because it suggests that co-stimulation
may have something to do with the
regulation of T cell differentiation and
so I'm going to show you the evidence
last less next lens to talk about so
just for those non immunologist there's
basically two schools of thought we know
that individual transcription factors
are associated with the differentiation
state of T sub cd4 T cells got a three
for example it said what are called th2
cells that make th2 type cytokines t-bet
is a transcription factor of the
determines that TD was the th1 fate
which make gamma-interferon tnf-alpha
ror gamma t since sales down th17
pathway to make house 17 in other things
then finally Fox p3 dictates the
function of these cells to me T reg
cells so this was thought as a linear
process so you've got a naive cell it
gets activated by antigen and what it
becomes depends on what's going on in
the environment at that time but several
years ago John O'Shea of the late Bill
Paul suggested that it's more of a
nuanced process that their intermediates
between cells they could go back and
forth or someone expects multiple
transcription factors and so it's been a
lot of support for this but but not a
lot of data so far and so anybody what
we're thinking missus this is done by
Spencer way is that one thing that that
that CTA Ford does on cells of course it
it can stop the response but also
attenuates the T cell signaling that
negative effects lower it so you know
the real strong antigen you might get a
maximum signal straight just here at
arbitrary units but if they attenuated
due to high levels of seed life for
expression it's much lower so if you
take seats like far away and they would
have give a signal strength that's much
higher than you can ever achieve you
know in wild-type max you get
supernatural if you will not
supernatural but super odd nights four
levels of t-cell I'm not trying to say
these are magic cell anything but but
but you could just get a much stronger T
cell receptor signal and we've known for
several years now due to work of Kim
Bottomly and others that stronger
signals tend to be associated with th
one type cells so we decided to look
just take C 24 away genetically and go
through this same sort of process and
see what we've got well the green and
blue dots here are wild-type and
heterozygous
and the red areas are see too late for
knockouts and what's apparent by the way
these are all CD fours with that same
pen well not with the same panel but
with markers two different subsets of
cd4s what you can see is there's this
group here and then this one here which
are clearly very different than the
cells that are you see in wild-type mice
and so what we think is that this is
represent cells that this represents
differentiate of space that's prevented
by the presence of seats like 40 cells
in normal mice never get a chance to go
down those pathways where if you remove
see to look for they they can and so if
you go back and you look at the kind of
cells that are there yet absent the
wild-type and lymph nodes and and hetero
and you see these cells these are our
friends the I cost positive TD T bat
positive cd4s these are the same cells
you get when you treat mice or humans
with with that are seats like for its
another population that's non non none
sauce to t-cell intermediate T cell that
has this one actually has T bet and then
you see this one over here as bcl6 got a
three ror gamma t so it has three
different transcription factors that's
really a confused cell it's made well
maybe an intermediate on the weight or
one of those other other pathways and so
there's another way to look at these
rather than looking at clusters it's
called archetype analysis where the
tumor you start with the T cell you want
with the cell you want and then measure
just going a little bit further away
from it and measure what what cells are
there until you get the ones that are
the farthest away from a starting point
and so that enables you to to tell the
difference between cells they might have
differentiated you know from there to
there directly as opposed to you know
you could tell if they follow this
pathway you end up with an archetype
here
here in here that are the furthest
difference that they can be from in this
case normal t-cell so these are the
extreme cells that are the farthest away
and so when Yuri analyzed the data about
that mathematical time you see to here
that it really here out these spaces out
in this you know I'm secretly four -
space the two that are most interesting
of cluster five and cluster seventh
cluster seven again as the I cost
positive pd-1 high these are the OCD
fours that we find when we treat mice
with anti seats like for these cells
they're really mixed up guys here and
again these are the it's not shown ever
these are fox be three positive so we
think then that this is evidence for the
fact that cyclic 4 is not just expanding
and cells were already there it may be
generating an entirely new cell by
sending it down on differentiation
pathway which is not possible in the
presence of seats like four so this is
something that an interesting thing that
we're working on further to get further
data but I want to come back to these
now because just didn't it's not that
these were unknown I'm just showing you
all that data because that's unbiased
it's just what the machines tell us but
these cells were actually discovered
about ten years ago by Pam Sharma and a
pre-surgical study in bladder cancer
anyway I cost as a member of the seed
cd28 seats life or family chose the tree
he's got a single ligand no my Casa
ligand normally if you tell them
immunologist i've got an i cost positive
cd4 I'll tell you it's a follicular t
helper cell which makes type 2 cytokines
or it's a regulatory t-cell neither of
which would do you any good in a tumor
and so as I said Pam Shaw my first
fountain needs to be increased in both
tumor and blood and patients after if
you live without treatment and she by
shortage so this at all of the cd4
positive gamma interferon and TNF alpha
cells that produced or produced in
response to tumor antigens study with
Jed wall shock show that that
crease was associated with longer
survival and then in mouth studies show
that they were essential for optimal
efficiency of Sita life for blockade in
other words if you do the therapies that
we had shown under conditions were to
get about a 90% response it would drop
to about 50% if you try to advise the
lack neither I costs or its ligand so it
appears to play an important role and it
seems to be by singling through pi/3
context to the Akt pathway and now show
you that this this is a really can be
considered positive checkpoint you could
target it to improve efficacy of sita
for signaling so it's a study that we
did to explore that where mice are given
tumor and then given anti ctla-4 and
along with either irradiated tumor cells
or radiated tumor cells that have been
transduced to express a constant and
these are all the singles antibody
controls this is the response rate that
you get when you have an acetal a 4 plus
the radiated wild-type tumor cells about
30 percent but that goes up to close to
90 percent if you just put a casa ligand
on the tumor cell and if you do that at
a cost knockout mice you don't see you
lose that effect so this shows indeed
that by giving in our seats like 4 and
then i costs agonistic i cost signals
you get a much more powerful cd4
response and i'm time to show you data
but it's because of about a 30-fold
increase in cells that make both gamma
interferon and TNF alpha so we formed a
company and made an antibody to this and
it's in trials now we don't know what's
gonna happen at least the preclinical
letters and it's pretty good so i'm
gonna just finish by saying that you can
block multiple checkpoints and I've
shown you negative and positive also
there's many things being explored you
know with our clinic viruses a local
ablation to enhance the United immunity
blocking other espresso factors vaccines
are coming along and finally genetically
targeted therapies in combination with
check
I think that what we're going to see in
the future is that checkpoint blockade
is going to become a part of essentially
all therapies and might be combined with
radiation or chemo therapies or many
many other things in counts of tumors
that don't respond well to checkpoints
by themselves so as to close and say
this is what we look you still looking
for go ahead and and in cancer therapy
for the last 30 years or so and that's
you treat a large number of patients and
and compare the median survival to the
standard of care or whatever and if you
move it over about a few months you know
that's a success and that's certainly
important to those patients who respond
but we know now from if you looma have
that you can do that but also have a
response rate of 20% or so in melanoma
patients that you know live for a decade
after a single round of treatment and of
course this is not data this is
aspirational but what we hope to do is
actually move that tail of the curve up
as high as we can get it there's many
kinds of cancer as we can and the good
news is I think we know the basic rules
there's still some frustrations and
glioblastoma pancreatic cancer for
example which haven't responded yet and
we need to get the response rates and
the patients who do respond up to again
it's close to a hundred percent as we
can and I'm optimistic you will succeed
if we keep going in with that I'll
finish and close and thank you very much
for your
[Applause]
[Music]